each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
so welcome everybody and it's a pleasure
to introduce sir Angelina from from Duke
who's also done postdocs at mpi and
elsewhere so universally yeah so and
also been locally in Oxford briefly as
well so Angelina it's a pleasure and
she's can talk to us about mechanism
design for cloud computing and
crowdsourcing so Angelina over to you
thanks so much for the invitation I'm
delighted to visit Microsoft Research my
talk today has titled megan is designed
for cloud computing and crowdsourcing
and let me first give you an outline of
my talk I first give you an introduction
to some basic notions that will come
again and again throughout the talk then
I'll talk about the problem of
scheduling selfish unrelated machines
and discuss the following aspects of it
and I will give it your multiple
characterization of truthfulness I will
discuss how you can get lower bounds for
truthful mechanisms and finally I will
discuss characterizations of truthful
mechanisms for this problem and then I
will switch gears and present the
scheduling with uncertain execution time
problem and where machines do not know
their processing times it's again a
scheduling problem though and finally I
will give you some of my I will tell you
about some of my future or sales plan to
have to do the cloud computing and
crowdsourcing and this is ty very well
with the previous problem so I believe
that whatever I will present about the
first problems is a solid background for
the last part and so we want mechanisms
that are truthful we want mechanisms
that don't give players an incentive to
lie let's consider a situation when a
player has an incentive to lie one day
before the elections the two big parties
are in dual and you have Captain Haddock
who is a true fun of the Green Party and
he sits and thinks should I vote for the
Green Party
or should I vote for determining who's
gonna be in the government and it turns
out since he prefers the red party to
the orange party he can't determine the
outcome of the elections so she should
vote for the red party and change
achieve a more preferable outcome by
lying about his preferences and so in
Megan's design generally we face the
situation where we need to make a single
choice for the whole society in voting
we need to select the single single
winner of the elections in public
projects we need to decide are we going
to build operate or not in options we
need to decide who's gonna win the item
and at what price and in scheduling we
need to decide which which machines are
safer scheduling which machines are
gonna get the tasks and what are they
gonna be paid and in other settings we
want to construct a function that takes
us input the preferences of many
different individuals and aggregates and
mom algun made them into a single
preference or choice and despite the
fact that someone might not agree with
the outcome of this function if you
construct if you design a game if you
give such payments such incentives to
the players so that the outcome of the
mechanism is an equilibrium then they
don't have one reason to deviate so
that's the whole idea of mechanized
assign even though the people might not
agree with the solution they don't they
don't have an incentive to deviate from
it and the most famous example of the
truthful mechanisms of Vikram economy
and the vicar mechanism applies to many
settings but the most simple the most
people of example of it is a single item
auction the bidder who bid the highest
wings and he pays the second highest bid
it is just that simple and it is
truthful so since uh since the winner
so the winner has valuation 10 since he
is anyway beating his anyway paying
eight he doesn't have an incentive say
to report nine and still win the item
you say what deviation you could do if
you use a first price auction and it
applies to many settings you can apply
for many items but however some for some
settings like a military elections it's
computationally inefficient and if you
have a different objective other than
maximizing the welfare maximizing the
happiness of the players that
participate in the auction then it might
not perform well because the vicar
mechanisms actually the mechanism can be
is equivalent to the meccans that
maximizes the welfare like there exist
payments afterwards that make it true
food so if your objective is not this
one you you might need a different
mechanism and now let's say move to the
scheduling selfish and related machines
problem and so the setting is the
following you have many players and
players and M tasks and the input to the
problem is a matrix of processing times
where the entry vij is the time that
player I needs the process dusty the
objective here is to minimize the
makespan the makes one is is exactly
what you can see in this picture if a
lot of machines a process it's the time
of the player who finishes last and the
output of a mechanic should be an
allocation of the task to the players
and payment the players will not process
the tasks if they don't get paid so if
we didn't use any payments at all they
would just tell us that they can't do
the tasks and that would be their best
but how do we determine how much they
get paid
and actually in this problem it'sit's
again one payment first player like
there is an allocate the output is an
allocation matrix so you have an entry a
IJ for its heyday which is either 0 1
the player gets a task or if he doesn't
get it so the allocation matrix is is
again a matrix like that and the
payments are one payment for its player
actually this problem it turns out that
the payments we can concentrate without
loss of generality on the allocation
part of the mechanism and that's a
that's why that's why I said the Mac the
victory mechanism is the mechanism is
equivalent of the mechanism maximize the
welfare and if you know that you can
find Jeffrey payments so if you have an
allocation rule that is truthful that
satisfy some properties will make it
through food then you can find true free
payments too yes trying to minimize the
completion time rather than trying to
maximize something measured in dollars
that's something measured in dollars you
know something related relating to early
and seems to me it's not obvious is it
that the objective function would be
which is the last task potential night
that's one possible objective function
but there are your budget minimize the
sum of the processing times day that's
usually you want to maximize something
which eventually is in the units of
dollars the use of money only makes me
maximize revenue or maybe I don't visit
make sense but it's just a different
problem but you'd certainly gained
intuition from one problem to the other
like you're having a maximization say
the vikram mechanism again is truthful
but with the reserve is is the solution
but the reserve price as very few plans
to find welfare i know it does the
happen i'm gonna do it now and thanks
for the question it's the sum of the
values of the players who welfare is
actually the sum the sum of the valuable
like a welfare in this problem aim in
options welfare is to give the task to
the players that that will maximize the
sum of the valuations you have a sum of
the valuations of the players who get
something but that is a single item
auction so it's very easy you just give
it to the player who isn't happiest
getting it that is a welfare if you have
many items the welfare would be to to
give the items to such players so that
the sum of the happiness of the players
is maximized that's what fer Pharaoh
truthful or whatever that word was
welfare is V what views yeah it was the
value on the previous slide so because I
hear you can again i might say welfare
its again to minimize the sum of
processing times so scheduling and
options are basically two two sides of
the same coin if you don't if you don't
concentrate on the allocation so if you
have say all possible mechanics for
scheduling you have all possibly
mechanics for auctions selfish kids mean
this is interesting to be able to
general about welfare functions isn't it
so this region only one sense oh you
know to Elena a third party to specify
what they consider to be the welfare and
then for you to have to say what is the
mechanism ha I vote objective like he
would have different objectives welfare
is one revenues another makes one is
another and for all the settings we want
mechanize that are truthful so studying
truthfulness in general helps us deal
with many different settings and many
different objectives and and the best
mechanism we have is the vcd Meccans
that maximizes a welfare that that's the
the simplest and sometimes it's too
lonely sometimes we can find many other
mechanisms that are true so we try to
approximate things by using the vicar
mechanism even in settings where we have
a different
detective okay so in this getting back
to this problem and player I is the only
person who knows the values of that are
in row I and since he's selfish he can
choose to report false values and the
location is 010 if the player doesn't
get task and one he does and okay what's
wrong with a victory mechanist that's we
just said that that's the thing that we
know let's try to apply it suppose that
we have the same put matrix so there is
one guy who is slightly epsilon is
positive you have a one guy who is
slightly fast around everybody else he's
gonna get all tasks and he's gonna take
three units of time and units of time if
you have n by n and then by an input
mechanism would be each task is
auctioned independently and each player
bits for it and since this guy is faster
on all of them he'll win all of those
independent auctions is that right it's
great that you got it I'm very happy
that's exactly that's exactly this case
yeah that's what you guys yeah it's too
stupid and so one way there are two ways
to generalize the vicar because you can
either run it on its task separately or
you can say it's the mechanist that
maximizes the wafer where the welfare is
what we agreed before it is and the two
are equivalent and it's awesome that you
just made this remark mmm so yeah here
and that's because the the the
valuations are additive you didn't have
other valuations that do not be the case
like in a combinatorial action with no
not evaluations even this would not be
okay like in scheduling you the Sun if a
guy like the time the first player gets
takes the processor the three tasks is
the sum of the values so if it would be
something like sub oddity or some
modular than it wouldn't be the case
but yeah that's that's a great
observation and the optimal thing would
be to parallel lies the tasks and to
just take one unit of time so that's why
the vicar Meccans doesn't do well in our
case and it has done an approximation to
the makespan objective that we chose so
this problem is very important in the
area of algorithmic Magnus design and
the reason is because it was proposed in
the paper that found at the area and it
also combines characteristics from the
two areas that of wits algorithmic
mekinese design consists economics and
algorithms it combines the very
important program of combinatorial
auctions with a classical scheduling
problem the scheduling unrelated muslins
problem and and i just showed you that
the vicar mechanics at saves on an
approximation and the best and the lower
bound that we know is only 2.6 so it's
it's open what is the best approximation
ratio that we cannot save the conjecture
by the way that the upper below the
upper and the lower bound design but
what people do but then you never know
and let's define truthfulness again more
formally and so fix the values of the
other guys and do I have an incentive to
deviate and lie or not players are
utility maximizers and we assume that
utilities are causal inner so we assume
that utilities our valuation manage
payment and so mechanism if a player who
has because type V doesn't have an
incentive to report time with type V
Prime and fly and to produce another
allocation here I'm hiding something
maybe you got it again
these value on all the allegations say
thanks thanks processing the fame the
ping he gets paid for doing the job
doesn't it yeah let's just because its
more common in options I mean it's the
other way around it's it's the same
thing I want to be minus sign minus I or
my whiskers from the valuations of the
other players yeah that's it that's
again a very good observation like it's
true that it's payment wise valuation
with you either minimize or maximize so
it's it's fine you know you you got it
right it's payment Moyes evaluation if
you want to maximize it if you want to
minimize it oh I oh you're gonna
actually type on my slide you're gonna
type on my slides that's meaningless I
mean it's either minimize the the the
minus or maximized uh yeah it goes to
some other players I did is there some
summer with evaluation of the other
players involved here also a signal
missing iono T so this it is one VI is
three what is being minus three it's a
matrix of reading time so here here you
take out the the road flare I and V mind
sighs the rest of the values that's it
actually hear it soon thank you it's a
whole medic unit with one really missing
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna use the
notation here i'm gonna use a notation
like I'm that that's better so here's
the input it's a matrix of brushing
times i use valuations to remind you
that it's the same with auctions right
and here's the output it's a matrix of 0
1 value
you get order you don't get the task and
the vector this is the vector flayer I
noted by Vi I skip the the vector
notation because it gets ugly but it's
mathematically sound because I use a
different letter and again truthfulness
is equivalent to this condition this
condition has a location and an input
like valuation on the location so you
take one input and its corresponding
output and another input and its
corresponding output the two inputs
differ only online i right it does
different on player I one player
deviates that's the situation we are
trying to consider here and then if you
just look at these rogue vectors of
player I forget about the other players
fix the values of the other players
that's v- I that's your matrix that you
ask me about these are all vectors have
to satisfy this inequality and if you
don't understand i'm gonna start
explaining you did it to you more
intuitively but it's it's called
monotone if eternity similar tone is
like for a single task it's but the
allocation is monotone so it's
modernistic for a multi-dimensional
setting and so that's this is this
condition is necessary and sufficient
for truthfulness and and here's the
geometrical interpretation let's say
that we have a single task and it it
tells us that the allocation should be
increasing with respect to the value of
player I when we fix the values of all
other players and because the allocation
can either be 01 if you have a small if
you if you can post process the task
very fast you have a small valuation you
get the task you get to process it then
there is a threshold and that depends
only on the values of the other guys of
the other players and your evaluate on
in your allocation things once and for
all from
20 this mechanism is not truthful why
isn't it well we have to find a
deviation say this guy here doesn't get
the task wait I know this guy here gets
a task hey sorry okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna choose this one and this guy here
doesn't get the task he wants he reports
a higher value but it takes him more
time to get the task he can he can get
it like this would with deviation in an
option it's like you could you could pay
less and you could still get the item
that's the equivalent in an auction so
there is a deviation if it doesn't have
the stressful behavior and so that's
what how i would like you to remember
Madonna states monotonicity how we say
in calculus and it's this fresco
behavior yes make a crucial assumption
that your payment is independent for
value right yeah I remember that I mean
depends on your ability for it depends
on your ability and the proof is very
singing I just scheduling context to
make your independent gonna be truthful
otherwise well you saying that s does he
sit up front there yeah that's a lot of
observation it select I was trying to
hide you and yeah but I I can prove that
any tree from my cannons has this
property that you just notice em okay
and let's say we have two tasks how does
monotonicity look like it's a Guinness
threshold that separates that gives the
slope of the separating hyperplane
between two different regions like here
it's the region where the player takes
both tasks and here to the region where
the player gets just the second task I'm
not only city tells us that this is the
separating hyperplane
and if they the two tasks if the two
allocations different to task then it's
going to be a sloped line 45 degrees
look nine and if we put everything
together get that all possible saves our
days and their turn you can substantial
aid them I just need the say to be like
that I just need this generalization of
the threshold behavior that I had before
so the region here here it's the the K
this is the input space the value of the
first start the valuation of the player
for the first task the valuation of the
player for the second task so this is my
whole input space though that's that's
what the mechanist has to give
allocations do and this Apes so which
allocations correspond to which part of
the input space so the truth or
mechanism has to partition the input
space in a very specific way and it can
only be this for the case of two tasks
of one player the two different tasks
for the decision does the other players
have everything fixed great no it's
awesome that you're falling yeah yeah
that's all and and actually if you think
of it it from Adam medical point of view
if you're a date once if you get the
other and the previews of the the one
that looks more like a threshold
mechanism but I will call it later
threshold megan's this is it the
generate version of the other two
because you can contract it two nodes
right m ok what's the geometry for three
tasks looks like that and that's up two
rotations like that all these shapes if
your Tatum you again get the truth from
mechanism and you can also have the
generate versions of this M
a nice was a reason is here that the
predictions are these 2d shapes and you
have either the 11 of them or the other
I am the I will just give you two hints
about the ingredients of the proof
monotonicity has to do if you want to
prove that to prove that the most honest
it isn't necessary is necessary for two
or three nice you have to consider
situation when a player has valuation V
and the Meccans gives allocation a and
he deviates and reports V prime and and
the other in another deviation when he's
through type is V Prime and he reports v
there is a way to give weight to this to
this graph I won't tell you how but
monotone list is equivalent to saying
that the graph has a positive weight and
actually this condition is also
sufficient for truthfulness that's why
I'd never talk about payments and for a
very nice proof for the sufficiency you
can see one of the endpapers has a value
allocation yeah so here it would be the
allocations value value a sorry why you
couldn't just think of it as allocation
basically yes so they're just exactly
two names then yes no no it's a one-note
for its origin of the previous age that
they that they gave me one for each
region okay what are the edges the edges
are something that is the difference of
the two allocations time the times the
day the valuation it is basically if you
look at the modern is the property and
you rearrange it it's AI minus a prime
times VI this part yeah
it's actually the supremum of that for
the whole region but you're asking too
much I was not planning to confuse with
all this detail and another proof idea
and I'm gonna be done with the geometry
after from this section is that you have
this complicated polytopes and the way
to deal with them is to look at the
boxes that contain them and if the box
is that contains two radians intersect
then the two mechanism the 22 region
share a common boundary and you just see
you have just to study the different the
distances between the boxes using
cycling modernist you can compute which
these are em I'm gonna get to the lower
bound section M okay so we just saw that
the the vicar a mechanist has an end up
isn't an approximation to make spar and
I'm gonna show you how you get the two
lower bound on truthful mechanisms you
just consider that was actually in the
paper that in the paper that found at
the problem and it's pretty simply
compared to the 2.6 lower bound so you
just consider this input and you use
this obsession so the general idea
behind it behind the lower bounds is
that monotonicity restricts the
algorithm that we can use very much you
already saw it in terms of the site like
the shapes are very very specific it's
not that you can partition the the input
space and in any way you like in order
to get lower bounds we will focus on on
pairs of of different inputs and their
corresponding outputs and we will see
what the what the allocation of one
instance means for the allocation of the
other one so we basically use this very
simple observation you can prove it
using the modernist
robert e if a machine gets a set of
tasks click here I say that the red does
Claire the tasks are allocated machine
one gets gets this two tasks and it
becomes a sorry max into a machine to
gets just get this red task and it
becomes even faster at it its value get
from one one moment to zero so you can
say epsilon a very small amount and then
that is vm bas denoted by the red the
red values m yeah sorry you in five okay
with you and okay so the second player
gets the first task and he becomes
faster at it if he becomes faster at the
tasks that he got then he still get that
you can prove using the monotony see
property and generally if you get if you
if she would get more tasks and you
become fostering the ones that you got
and slower the in the tasks that you
didn't get then the allocation doesn't
change and here I'm hiding you some web
salons that you have to take you to be
careful about but it's basically this am
so you start with this instance and
using this property you just you just
consider this two possible locations and
using this property twice you you again
end up with with this way of proving
lower bonds but you cannot do that from
four matrices that are having more
players so the way to get the one plus
the golden ratio lower bound is to
consider an input like that and to to
consider the two cases the one is when
one player gets all tasks at what that's
what the basic CD mechanist would do the
Vickery mechanics would do oh actually
ace ace here variable and we will solve
for it so what we get the best lower
bound that we can it's going to be the
golden ratio but we're just keep it at
variable in the beginning so that we can
find the the best possible value for it
and the best possible value for it is
determined by balancing between
performing bad in these two situation
the one is when the when one guy takes
all tasks and the other is when at least
one one task goes to another player so
if one guy gets hurt us the best thing
to do is the bit to paralyze the
procedure and to have a diagonal
location and the ratio of the the the
cost of a rope this is this one this is
a geometric series in this other case we
can prove using a complicated induction
and strengthening the induction
hypothesis that the approximation ratio
of the mechanisms at least 1 plus alpha
and solving this equation you would get
the golden ratio so it's basically in
order for the mechanisms not to perform
bad in any of the two cases you have to
make these two quantities equal and you
get the lower bone okay no we don't have
any particular mechanism in life you're
saying that any mechanisms annuities
monitor city or truthfulness exactly
will could be as bad as or in fact would
never be though there will be some
problems fortune would be as bad as two
and a half times worse than what do we
do sorry stands for a week so we perform
buddy like its worst case analysis when
we just have to improve the 2.6 letter
ball and the upper bound is then it's
wide open but if we didn't insist on
truthfulness maybe we could go maybe I
lower bound will get better uh what
would be your alternative for
truthfulness I mean you've just said
truthfulness is that I kind of and it's
just something you assume is good yeah
right but it forces this bad results on
you yeah so maybe you should question
the assumptions there are several ways
to question the assumption and you can
either look at them before mechanisms or
you can use look at fraction allocation
or I randomized allocate
but for most of these cases the
situation is very similar env3 the env3
case has been solved on every furnace is
pretty similar to truthfulness but again
you don't get the constant you never get
a constant approximation and the
fraction on the randomized version of
the problem is has exactly the same
behavior with different proof so m okay
so we didn't we we can we did just as
good as 2.64 the lower bound and have
this huge gap so and we only know one
mechanism the Vickery mechanism maybe we
know a few more I can we prove that
these are the only possible mechanisms
or can we start finding other mechanisms
and so the vicar in megan's i would like
to you to remember the vicar maccon's
for multi parameter settings as the
Meccans that maximizes the social
welfare and that's enough because i told
you that the payments are if if you have
a truthful occasion you can just
concentrate on the allocation part and
forget about the payment and and you can
generalize the vicar mechanism in terms
of a fine maximizers the affine
maximizers just take the objective of
the social welfare and optimize awaited
social welfare and remember the geometry
we discussed before the vicar Meccans
allocates its task independently that's
that was your observation but you look
at its column and you allocated suckling
Bentley the geometry of tasks of megan's
at the allocated Sasuke looks like that
because there is a threshold you get the
top you get the first task you don't get
it m and finally matter might look like
that so it's much more general in terms
of geometry am and except for for these
mechanisms the the vicar mechanisms is
generalization and we also have
threshold mechanisms this don't allocate
exactly its task independently that
would be allocating sask independently
and they still have the say
they still have a threshold for its task
that does not depend on the other task
and if you if you ask me which values
can affect the allocation a 12 it is
this red value so it's no other value of
player 1 but it might be the rest of the
matrix and and these are why was he said
something influence is something else
for some reason I said that you do not
need necessarily to just allocate its
task independently you could use this
value to determine if player 1 gets task
to or not which is the value of player 1
for for the second task it sounds
irrelevant but I'm just looking for all
tripping mechanisms so I'm trying to
find you know even weird mechanisms that
looks weird I mean it's not going to
help us minimize the makespan but if I
want to characterize you have to think
of all crazy examples and that's what
it's doing but I think the way to think
of it is that it's that it has this
geometrical picture and that locates
it's almost independently but these
values are pretty relevant for for
allocating the task or not if you don't
have the rest of the values and and for
the case of two players we can't prove
that the only decisive truthful
mechanisms are either a fine minimizer's
or threshold mechanisms and and if you
have more tasks it's again a combination
of a fine minimizer's and threshold
mechanisms imagine is that thing the
geometrical picture has already earned
it like no rating disappears I haven't
shown you its own you known decisive
mechanism but if you would if you would
make one region disappear to be known
this size so for fixed values of the
other guys the one player can achieve
all allegations by beating accordingly
it's it's not a big assumption but it's
pretty done pretty and often you use but
yeah
this is just assuming edit evaluation so
since you sent you have just a single
primitive type it's not single parameter
by any case the year monkey enough chose
with a treat with your payments and less
being relax you're asking about
threshold mechanism yeah that's that's a
great observation it's they are the only
exists for additive valuations they
don't exist in camara looks good yeah
that's true that's actually the only
domain where like the biggest of me the
more general domain where they exist mmm
and yeah some some products that I just
submitted is a characterization of ice
water to mechanism these are making that
where the more than easy property holds
with inequality em I was auctioning out
you're chewing the first task and if you
if you win right then I'm going to be
less keen to give you another task
because you're being some of your
execution time is used up now what I
mean the auctioneer might become less
keen to allocate this makes a strange
that completely independent auctions
yeah but I mean that's not gonna be
truthful if you want to stick to drift
but it's also not not clear what what
you're gonna do if you relaxed ruthless
with some others but yeah I mean it's
it's a natural thing to think of person
completely depended options it's a bit
of an unrealistic well it's not no no I
mean like who's saying we put up your
racial draft that one minus of silence
for one
we describe you had a vertex there are
metrics in which you have one rule was
all 1 minus of Cylons yes except Allah
Jen causes ostrich energy allocate all
of the tasks to there's one protest all
right and therefore it comes over the
course em but what your basic what my
understanding of this graph is that you
are saying that because one of the
bettors has more money and you run all
of the options in parallel that the
better is able to use their more money
in all options in parallel in order to
win all the goods of course that's
complete nonsense right you can't you
can't run all the options of parallel or
either send better to use their higher
amount of money in all the options
simultaneously butter on the options
eventually they run might have money
they can just keep using the same money
that's the part I didn't understand I
understood the rest of the argument and
that's its social sequentially the
columns here of the auctions you're the
ransom Dempsey it's it's just equivalent
around them if you run sequentially then
after you delegated the first task to
the first the agent we no longer have
the opportunity to complete a subsequent
task in 1 minus epsilon because it was
already be busy would have to bid to
minus epsilon awesome yes the point the
victory mechanism would give you your
optimal I come right so the problem is
that you decided it is ok to run all the
options in parallel I'm not really
running our locks and super let's just
that I mean just say I'm have a
community election and I want to find
the welfare maximizing allocation and I
find that and it turns out that it's the
same with running or locks and
sequentially this is
and so I didn't have the chance like
from the way the problem was defined I
didn't have the chance to allocate its
inability but of course it makes a lot
of sense to study options that are
sequential but it wouldn't be truthful
here and that's not the problem I'm
starting but it's it's not it makes a
lot of sense here and it's happening
down like four options i'm not sure
about scheduling you don't think
anything actually think it's hardly
begun on the phone information study
where she means we know the value
company with a little india and i think
i'm gonna skip this problem unless you
give me more time okay um okay so this
problem is again a scheduling problem
you can also think of it for more tasks
I'm gonna just talk to you about the
single test case but you can just run
and separate dachshunds for its task and
put them together like we discussed
before and here the goal is different
it's to minimize the processing time the
some frosting times and and we have the
notion we're going to deal with the
notion of eternity like that's a key
ingredient of this problem so the
mechanics designer is say the Queen and
she wants a painting for her pilots and
every day she can decide who wit painter
is gonna paint and and the play the
painters don't know exactly how much
time it's gonna take them to finish a
masterpiece but they have an estimation
ok so it's painter has the painting time
that he needs to finish his painting and
it comes it is a draw from a
distribution or if I
so before why we just really want
anything but whoever finishes it first
he's gonna put it in the palace and the
rest are gonna burn their paintings or
whatever so yeah the distributions are
independent from each other and we
assumed the utility of the players is
again time spent in painting- payment so
its valuation my payment em and we also
shown that the the painters have
monotone hazard rate distribution also
in the previous problem the types were
with a number the processing type now
there are distribution so the input of
the problem is now a vector of
distributions mmm so the monitor hazard
rate says that the more time a painter
takes the less lighting his the finish
so it's like he got in a creativity he's
not creative anymore or he's trying to
do something very hard actually you
could you can think of it does the
crowdsourcing problem too so you want to
solve a hard problem and by running a
contest and you would like to have
payment 0 for whoever fails to finish
soon a solution and you have uncertainty
because if the if the problem is hard
enough then you don't know how much time
will take you and the immature of
consumption makes sense the hazard rate
assumption because the probability of
finding a solution in the beginning
might be easy if the problem is very
easy but then it it might take forever
you don't know em so because of the
immense our assumption we can prove that
the greedy algorithm is optimal and so
what what the Queen has the dough is
that it's day she has to go to the
painters and assign
assign the to the painter who has the
maximum hazard rave assigned to the
player who is most likely to finish on
the very next day greedily em we know
the vikram mechanism i told you so much
about it but it isn't ruffle expected
vicar it's not ruffle we have to take
expectations because um because the
types are distribution and the example
is suppose that you have these two
painters just look at the first time
step and El Greco is more likely to
finish on the first time step she gets
to paint but she could report that he is
even more likely to finish on the next
on the first time step and the idea
behind this is that it looks like that
we don't really need the mm wait oh we
will not only really use the leap to
paint because like an expectation el
Greco will finish at the first time step
very highbrow build so in expectation
Dallas contribution is very small so el
Greco gets a bigger payment but that's
because we we asked the paper the player
for the values and then we gave them
payments and we didn't look at what they
did so the solution is to use the
realized times of the painters and
suppose that this is the El Greco gets
up in the first and second day dolly the
third and learn our da Vinci to the
fourth and we get a finishing time here
el Greco gets the masterpiece first and
so we're gonna run a mechanist that
gives these payments it's minus the sum
of the values of the of course the
winner is it is El Greco that the guy
who fixes and the payments are going to
be minus the sum of the other guys
that's exactly the gross payment and i'm
going to show you in a minute why this
is the gross payment and why this makes
a mechanist referred
the objective of the mechanism to
minimize the sum of processing times
right it is it is this thing is actually
the expectation of this thing and El
Greco wants to maximize his valuation so
by giving him this payment you just make
this two things equal so that's the idea
behind the vicar mechanism that's that's
how I like to remember it I don't like
to remember it as a second price I can I
like to remember it as a mechanism give
such payments so that the objective of
the safest players becomes the same as
the objective of the mechanism signer
and you cannot always do that but you
know for the welfare you can it's easy
to do that like that and actually the
sort of the proof that not only they
don't have any incentive to lie but they
also don't have an incentive to miss
computer and it's crucial that we use
the days that he painted but also in the
days that other people painted before he
finished that's the grove extra day in
your picture so here is his payment is
he's very good he's basically what she
know what she did society like how hard
it would be he wasn't there I was just
looking bottom line looks like he gets
hey I thought you were gonna think that
the payments are negative which I was
trying to but there is a way to make
them positive I I'd like you to remember
just this thing that you just do you
look at the objective you look at the
utility and you just subtract the
objective in detail and we get so that
you make this two things equal and and
yeah and we devise an unexposed to make
these the payments are negative but
there is a function that you cannot and
we monitor divisor a mechanist that
doesn't pay a player who doesn't
complete the task uses the realize
values it satisfies individual
rationality and expectations of
years want to participate in expectation
it has positive payments and this but
it's the best interest of the players to
exert effort and finally a very brief
discussion about cloud computing and
crowdsourcing and so cloud computing has
received the way we we see computer
nowadays it has turned tail it to a sort
of public utility and we we go to a
website we press a button we open the
top and we get network servers storage
applications and services and they're
easily configurable and on demand and
it's also a characteristic that users
arrive and depart whenever they want and
but why is it loud sulfus what has
gained theory to do with some with cloud
computing what coming model using
Meccans design and game theory so again
first say okay can I model it as
something that I know can I model is a
congestion game as a scheduling problem
like the ones we saw before self
scheduling can I model it as an auction
or a market or maybe we need the new
model probably that but will gain some
intuition from the previous ones showing
in this one problem we have multiple
players and multiple users who arrive
and depart and they have different
requests there are multiple providers
both users and providers are selfish and
the providers also have to decide an
allocation which which players they're
gonna service and at what price and and
there is certainly uncertainty about
what the demands of the players are
going to be they have to estimate their
demands they sometimes over booked em
and then even though cloud meeting
abstracts computing from the physical
machines it is always
a problem how to assign an efficient
levi how to efficiently divide a
computer into many different virtual
machines and how to firmly assign tasks
to multiple cores and memory and decide
which tasks are need more memory in
which need more computing power and of
course here you're probably gonna think
yeah it's also a scheduling problem
because you need to split the jobs into
tasks and assign them to multiple cores
so the problems that we discussed so far
can help us with dealing with some of
these aspects and then there is a the
question of what prices do we use
probably oh all these cases are
realistic and not one of them is a good
answer so maybe the the company the
cloud provider is poster prices or maybe
they there is a spot market and the
prices fluctuate or maybe there is a
negotiation like there is an option that
is run by the by big company who wants
to use that one sees cloud computing
services and cloud providers bid and
finally cloud providers are selfish
players and why do they have an
incentive to be accountable it could be
responsible as a company so maybe we
need an external Authority an external
trusted authority that has something
like a rating system hey or give them
incentives that in order to be
accountable and this is my last slide so
crowd sourcing and crowdfunding and the
machines are more like or more skin and
you can complete much more complicated
tasks you can't even translate the web
like you do into a lingo mm but it's
it's a very big talents to decide how to
split
complicated very big jobs in Dublin too
many tasks and how to give incentive to
the players to complete the tasks and
how to ensure that the solution is of
high quality that's it thanks for the
extra time